incoming challenge
yay hello and welcome to this broadcast
our weekly show on Mondays yeah I hope
it works alright we have tried a new set
up here and I think it looks fine I hope
you all like it actually forgotten
something now that I know that I see the
whole thing in I forgot a little
something it's tough it's tough to
change the old habits here we go so
let's get going here and I changed the
software here and it is some now on my
usual software dasher so I feel like
right at home so let's get going here
with a couple of five-minute games I see
lots of people in the chat and that's
really cool hope you all participate
okay we'll get going last week I managed
to kill about 100 rating points from
2,400 down to two thousand three hundred
and below it was a really bad session
but I worked really hard the last two
days to get my rating back so you'll see
a 2400 again for me to eat so again
trash it in this session um yeah that's
a question by prashanth alles wat the
last round of Ted steel um yeah I did
not manage to cover that I was very busy
on the final round sunday and also on
the Monday Tuesday after that it has
nobody complained as sort of didn't do
it hmm so if there's huge interest I'm
going to still cover that round but I
didn't feel it was so particularly
exciting to be honest um and what the
what the beep I'm I'm out for a five
minute game and I don't get
this is curious yeah we have the new
setup here everything's nice and now no
one wants to play what is this game
started okay let's see um I go deform
and yes I will cover my league game
against Alex and a cough Sean definitely
will do that it's just a very nice game
and it will be will be on my channel so
i'm playing the exchange sloughing
against cheatin if not that's probably
not the right pronunciation but I do my
best ok I'm happy to trade on the six
and play a 4 here this is a nice form of
the exchange Slav sort of a reverse
Stonewall yeah I will actually produce
more than just the one video on my
league games there was also a very
interesting and very interesting game
that I played in the December f6 Oh
what's not move I expected
well II five is very difficult to play I
mean I can just take you five for
example so I just develop him
ji looks like a nice position amber a
nickname given to Myanmar gambit files
Mukesh yeah the translation is if
possible please play amaura gambar to
Smith Maura it's tricky i have to play
one year for maybe add a secret oh he
allows me to take on d5 hmm Jim I can
also take on e5 here and play Bishop c4
also possible okay I'll take here first
there's a question what's the idea of
the maroc see when you play the night to
see two besides avoiding the trade and
the main thing is actually to avoid the
trade this is very helpful if you can
avoid trading okay I can I think I'll
just take care there should be six is
irritating me a little bit this is why
I'm still thinking here Bishop c4 is
also move okay I'll play Bishop c4 I
don't know was a tough decision maybe
night takes you three now yeah the the
Mora gambit the Smith Mora is really
often declined even form of our champion
vishy anand declined the gambit against
Mark esselman and in the gibraltar
tournament 95 maybe it's more
complicated than i wanted but ok let's
see what happens
you
yeah I mean wish she definitely knew
that s women would play the Smith Morris
oh this is some indication that the
gambit is quite okay I actually believe
so myself I think that accepted the more
i accepted gives white decent chances
I'm pretty pretty sure if you look at
this a little bit it looks like um it's
a dangerous opening em okay what is this
if i take i will takes you four hands
it's not that great here and the bishop
is hanging completely hanging
I have no idea what's going on I have no
idea what's going on Nats FYI go queen d
5 I should have played something else
this is what I know something simpler
and just try to refute his five but I
mean I tried to refuel it but I didn't
do it good do it well okay yeah this is
probably just better 95 he takes on c
forum Chim amazing amazing yeah this is
this is rubbish but I had no other and I
didn't have anything else oh ok at least
I'm not a porn down immediately they can
take on it for of course yeah this is
what this is the skills you can do but
at least I'm reasonably active here this
is not bad I've got some slight chances
to draw at least rook endgame for
example is always having some some
drawing chances and g5 blunders the
house so we cannot do that 49 f six hmm
now I'm I'm not enthusiastic about this
but might might be okay 22 to 25 for a
draw yeah this is famous game mark s
women with white against Luke valve le
where a sermon yeah played a fantastic
attack against
then really some King really really
great game night is seven here it's not
super convincing energy for maybe let's
go on h4 I mean sorry my idea is to
weaken the g5 porn so that I have rookie
five now yeah okay so here this is
giving some chances to draw against the
active rook
okay going to try to trade that check
and now I just have to trade down the
queenside for the draw hi morning shoot
the such a simple move and I just had to
play be four first or something like
that nothing happens ah I had to draw
here already that was bad that was bad
the drawing chances were really high and
now we're just losing I awful awful
I just totally lost that sets rubbish
White Rose I ok and I said I want all
the points to to give give it give them
back in this session here on Monday
playing stupid end games like this ok um
match with ginger GM yeah I'm happily
playing one I'll take care about that I
mean he did he never messaged me about
it and I want to I want to to ask him
when I've got my my move completed and
time a little bit more focus in starting
to learn the Mora for a tournament about
2,000 dido opponents well i don't know i
know that you allow the younger player
so not sure if you have you still have
chances to play you can also play other
lines against a sicilian to actively
start employing this opening i'm not
sure of such a great idea even if you
already play it I don't really mind but
learn it hmm I don't know
grandmaster jasper is that just before
or who is that lasse Karlsson ok not
magnus carlsen lasse karlsson and okay
what about this maybe I can fight for
getting in d5 here before I have
controlled yeah but his development is
not great he has wasted lots of time on
age three a three no I've never played
in the park in Stuttgart with giant
pieces I have never have been to shoot
God do too but just to switch trains or
something I've never been in the city
center on anything like that so I'm
sorry I don't don't know those giant
pieces let's see how to do that maybe
I'll start with this jay and the trade
here i wonder if i should go see six
year or i can evil it's not possible
unfortunately tween 27 bit 5 is also
interesting
I don't know if chest position trainer I
know that it exists but I never used it
my usual way of looking at an opening
was too yeah enter the main things i
look at into into chair space into the
database and analyze a little bit myself
and enter enter enter thing some data
analyze myself i have from books let's
go let's go here i'll be 5s maybe a move
hmm very strange position okay I'm
taking here if he takes GTX 93 is just
killing white so I'm a little bit
surprised by castling okay so what now
and he did not intend this but it is
still quite okay for him hmm surprising
to play d4 c5e for is a very good idea
and Wendy 45 is not particularly great
so if you feel you don't do well then
there's something wrong with your one
default play you shouldn't transpose
into the Smith maroc I mean you can do
that in a blitz game or something like
that but i think it's a it's a very very
strange idea to do that yeah just just
learn how it works the venom is it's
it's basically a good opening for white
I mean not that it is terrible but if
you are worried about that then your
choice of going 1 d4 is probably
questionable if you want to put it like
that okay I'm trying to open this up
even though I'm opening up his his Queen
as well oh it just takes check
yeah that's a good question Victoria
skull asks in a 5 plus 1 tournament over
the board should the focus be to play
good chess moves or to play kind of
average moves quickly yeah I mean 5 plus
0 is still a reasonable amount of time
it's not it's not bullet chess or
anything like that so you can still try
to play decent moves and as far as I'm
concerned it's doable so try to play
decent moves still of course you cannot
spend spend ages 92 I wanted to play
Bishop g1 check but you can take with
the rook you can take with the rook I'm
such a [ __ ] sometimes so I have to do
this here to not lose the house probably
has to lose the house no i don't i get
c6 but i will have some counter play
against them against the king here I
guess the B porn I mean
maybe I can still do stuff against the
skin while not allowing the pawn
promotion night-night h5 for example
yeah night h5 now is that a move he
takes check hmm might be it might be dry
I can also do this first okay now taking
won't help I actually miss countered him
ha i miscounted this stuff I can
probably draw here if I can sacrifice
the the the night against the B part
it's a draw but i don't know if i get
them
time warning check check I don't see if
I don't see if I get them I don't get
don't get in the in the corner nice got
Bishop c6 also it's just lost it just
lost it's the only way to describe this
position they're just losing Bishop b5
h4 and I'm losing and it's pretty easy
ah terrible check
yeah and you just goes there ah what am
I doing here yeah this is like a good
offbeat line against the other coins um
okay let's do this it's not a blitz game
I just show you a good off behind
against the elegance this is a pretty
decent off bit line and let me think
about it andy sixx d 4 takes Queen h5
this is a decent offbeat line okay that
that can be played with them with very
little theoretical knowledge okay let's
shoot for a new game start I am Krupa ok
this guy I have five point five out of
six games I have a huge score i am so
let's see if i can win against him and I
I think you place the classical Dutch no
it doesn't okay and so we get a queen's
gambit
yeah the clock is going during the
analysis because it was from from the
game I didn't hi out a full analysis
board why does a couple of tempo moves
here that I can that I can play see what
he's doing yeah I'll take the space
support this with f4 yeah that is a
decent position maybe have six is coming
jack hmm this takes a long time or just
clean f2 soil for an endgame come on
let's let's pay let's play that good
endgame I have lost two games already
check and getting some kind of endgame
torture here is this is what I want my
idea is a four-year this position open
up the position for the bishops takes
and then before or if I immediately will
be okay he prevented that but now on g4
is hitting
he has a hard time to keep the center
yeah okay I take your engine then windy
594 that's a check but I have to be
cautious not to run into some funky
mates there it is two nights other than
that the position is fantastic night to
c7 coming for example on Bishop 6 okay
where to go here kingi to looks wrong
king my king position is not not ideal
still 97 is a pretty awkward idea was he
going ahead with the aid or something
like that yeah 97 that's not working
yeah it's difficult here so 97 I'm just
grabbing stuff so pooped III here or
if he plays some bishops eat or so I'm
just
I can also take the bishop now not a a
troop c 1 king e to look see to this is
a draw I'll be damned amazing
amazing stuff here
or can he even win here and that would
be that would be crazy yeah I don't know
look b3 Roxy 7s and my look is totally
misplaced and I don't see how I'm not
losing their book c1 is a huge threat
this is what did I do that yet a totally
unplayable position out of the opening
it really was completely completely
complete recluse in this position there
now I'm lost here that's that's very
cool check check yeah I think Bishop c4
is actually winning
I'm so tied down I don't see how I'm not
losing Roxy monokini to Bishop c4 hmm
yeah check you have a bad run chan you
can mostly just continue to play draw a
third game let's have a quick look there
I'm come I'm not sure I was thinking
chad is this and he has this move I am
totally tied down totally tad on the
engine says sets through equal 0 0 0
wants to do this night age for Bishop g3
and now comes with distance this chat
completely Becky line and check and this
is this is a perpetual some kind of
perpetual um crazy okay I need a new
game and now I would definitely take a
notebook to a tournament especially if
you feel that there are games of your
opponents what I wouldn't do is I'm in
games of your opponents in a database to
prepare for them what I would not do is
let's say you have a round coming up and
you have six hours until their own
starts don't sit there for five hours on
that laptop and that notebook and try to
figure out what your opponent is doing
then you waste all your energy for the
game but it is a good idea to invest in
our so and get an idea what this kind of
person is playing yeah what kind of
player are you dealing with and maybe
check if they play a particular opening
a particular line that you really feel
uncomfortable with then it is an idea to
to look something up but don't invest
four or five hours and completely
exhaust yourself this is a very bad idea
something that I that I tended to do
when I was a lot younger and now i just
i do some prep but i don't do more than
this is really strictly necessary okay
um i'm playing the Queens gambit the
client here and see what we get play the
tartar cover okay so white played a very
natural sound setup here may be shooting
for e for here black has options I can
play in in various ways with c 6 and so
on I'll go for c 6 year 9 a-6 97 96 not
sure that this is the best set up
against this particular line no I
haven't played on chest cube for ages I
wasn't even aware that the server still
is existing I played on that for a while
like two or three years ago but it it
seems like the activities is going down
there all the time oh it seemed back
then this would be the right way to
phrases and I didn't see much point in
playing them for any serious chest like
five minute blitz and so on the ICC is
the best platform anyway but chess cute
back then had some some some funny some
funny tournaments their form for pure
entertainment value it's not bad or
what's not bad but I think it's probably
basically dead nowadays and that said if
you want yeah serious competition that
icc is to this the place to go yeah you
for now it's a slightly awkward to
hmm interesting interesting I can take
on before now i don't know if it's good
but i can i can do it it's a I don't
know it's a good idea if I take that's
not be five though so i probably have to
check I don't have any concrete
tournament plans yet this year I will
play some open tournament in the summer
but not not sure which one or what time
exactly and so on and many pretty
undecided and it also depends on some
some things with my upcoming move to a
new place I already talked about that a
lot in recent shows but it just it you
know this is this kind of thing it just
costs enormous amount of money and I
definitely cannot I cannot afford any
fancy dis destinations what the for any
tournament not this year ok um he's got
a nice night coming up there to see six
wow I'm really struggling here and this
in this session again really wonder what
that is sometimes I've got a plate today
for a long session and I really played
well I againt decade like 100 points
from to 350 2 to 4 50 and here i am not
doing anything good um yeah I'm I'm
moving from my current place in induce
book to my hometown of Dean's Larkin
heads it's a small small town about
60,000 people it's the place where my
chess club is also located so I'm moving
closer to my club this is not the real
reason but it's just my hometown and I
know things there and when I was ya
lookin for a place i was looking my
current current city and also the one
where i was before simply because i have
a rough idea what a good places and so
on
the best mindset for players that are
playing in tournaments where they
slightly out of depth is an idea to go
for completely draws lines I think some
solidity does not hurt but completely
draws lines um it's not so easy anyway
um and I think that the most important
thing is that you still play you are
that you still play your brand of chairs
if you are a solid player play solidly
if you an aggressive player play
aggressively it's really important to
not try to be someone that you are not
and this is this is a mistake that that
actually many players make they think oh
this is a difficult event I have to do
something I have to do something special
yeah and what what you have to do is you
just have to play to your strengths and
and see what happens I should have
played a six year maybe a six and b5
that would have been good i think i
actually think i'm ok here now anyway
but that position was much worse at one
point yeah white maybe a tactics david
franklin is right about there in the
chat i has a question do I believe in
feng shui I never really looked into it
so I have no clear opinion
I thought I have to cover Roxy 7 but
this this is actually quite annoying
Bishop c6 now maybe
hmm
oh I don't know I'm not saying that this
is bad I just felt he might might have
had something even better gypsy 6 is
still not looking good check
how do how do I actually get to that
damn porn it's that way to get to the
pawn 9 to e seven maybe
it really looks like I should be busted
but I don't see it I currently don't see
it look a one may be okay one I had
feels like dodging bullets here okay
yeah that didn't help him so much I
think ik went to before can I go I five
now time money or is that crazy I could
be crazy ii five Bishop chicks I don't
see how I'm losing so let's try this one
well it's a good move maybe I can still
do this I really feel like oh he got me
finally he he tricked me finally here
okay I return his time management wasn't
great and this is actually not ah I come
on I should should blunder everything
here oh it doesn't take be sex for it I
goodness ah oh my goodness yeah today is
a hose in montauk day of the carnival in
Germany but no I don't do do the
carnival not a fan I don't know I think
people I mean everybody should do what
they want to do but not my thing
my main objection with it is actually
that you have so many drunk people like
hanging around and I know I simply don't
like large crowds of drunk people I mean
a perfectly fine with drinking a beer
here and David when I was still working
in in Dusseldorf if you are you know Joe
me that you know that Dusseldorf is one
of the big places for the carnival
celebrations when i was working still
there and working at that time of the
year was always a disaster because you
have so many drunk people around game
started um ok Carol em too let's see and
what I do I think about Manchester chesa
ball um I don't know it I simply simply
don't know what I know chesa balazs the
project where John Ruffolo meu is
involved it's something about learning
openings sorry but I haven't looked into
it I think it's supposed to be live in
soonish but I haven't as I said I happen
to look into it I saw a couple of
minutes of John's intro video about
about about the thing but that's a bad
move what am I playing here nights and I
need to be ready to play Bishop f4 in
this position okay the Dutch defense I
could play a Dutch defense i got a
request for the smiths mora actually
this is a head should have played a
4-bit playing a form if I'm in a shaky
form like this always feels like some
some kind of Japanese suicide ritual
like oh and yeah you got that
that big sword right in your chest here
at least I really know what I'm doing
I'm probably going to record one or two
of my over the board the game videos in
the next couple of days yeah you can
play d4 here and again that's not
looking good I'm really playing badly
just really really bad this position
wow it's really a bad position chesa
bull is a paid site you say you bought
this you um okay well it might be if you
are let's say I'm you you're a student
or whatever you don't have you don't
have any money I understand that you
probably prefer to prefer to be chat
services to be for free but the thing is
people who work and will invest time
they need to earn money and I actually
think that providing too much content
for free is a big mistake something that
I see that that something likely chess
is very popular because it's for free
but what they do there for free is
actually from a business sense a very
bad idea you have to UM yeah you have to
be willing to pay for good content
otherwise you don't get it in the long
run because people simply run run out of
run out of money let's say I mean for
example I do some free things like the
YouTube videos and so on but it all has
its limit because I have to have to pay
for my expenses and if I do everything
for free I assembly I simply can't do it
I simply can't so um it's a I think if
it's a good service it should be paid
yeah and what am I doing here actually
I'm trying to somehow get stuff me as
king it's totally it's a totally bad
position strategically but that's a good
move that's a good move by Carol
really really bad yeah my my game this
game here is a complete disaster a
complete disaster from start to finish
playing this like a beginner almost
yeah google and facebook they earn all
their money due to do to add ads of
course this is a way to do it but this
is only working in large scales ya know
look at look at youtube forum for chess
i mean even the the biggest YouTube
channels they they don't earn chess
YouTube channels they don't earn any
substantial money to live from even guys
like Jerry from from chestnuts work
right he runs pretty nice money from
YouTube but he cannot live live of that
run the least bit absolutely absolutely
cannot do that and what I get from
YouTube is a pure joke oh he's
sacrificing that's surprising not really
necessary to be honest looks a little
bit like he is afraid of my pseudo
attack here and it really is nothing
serious at all
after that he's got d3 actually my
original intention was to play route 66
which does not work at all ok man I have
to allow the trade which is unfortunate
i can take it one play Queen III that
will win quite easily check yeah hutch
is not a chess streamer I mean he plays
chess but he's mostly I think posting
gaming content but I never watched any
of his stuff Jack oh this is one of the
worst games ever I wonder how many
points does he have like roughly a
million right and Queenie 3m he has the
the Queen trade
yeah Tim just there you can just play
that and win rather easily check what
actually and now he gets the roof
trading but okay I mean this is a nice
blockade maybe this isn't so bad
actually and since no that's not easy he
cannot move his pawns hmm isn't isn't as
good as good for black I don't know can
still do this now can run to the Jeep on
now I have to do this stop this stuff
blog more fits on you I won them on time
oh my god oh ok I am going for one more
so let's see yeah i mean i have a rough
idea what those people make with their
chest channels because i know what i'm
making and it's basically nothing and
you can multiply up they have you counts
and so on it's not it's not great either
okay i'm playing blind faith scream so
what is it blind faith or cream or both
let's see the engine on the last game
now I was probably down the engine is
probably giving giving a super clean win
for my opponent
you got in YouTube you get paid for
clicks clicks on the advertisement so if
you use an ad blocker for example then
I'm not getting any money I mean and if
you if you don't if you use the ad
blocker I mean if you don't use it and
you again you actually click on one of
the advertisements i won like three
cents or something like that you
essentially get very very little it only
works with with with huge figures you
have those people like yeah I don't know
those million subscribers stuff of that
the same would i play the same amount of
chest without my youtube channel um I'm
not sure I probably it's probably
probably similar I it's hard to tell
because when I was not a full-time chest
professional with with teaching I think
I actually played a little bit more
because I would often play long sessions
in the evenings after coming back from
the office or even the whole weekend's
just yeah but now if you if you teach
for a couple of hours and then you like
play for one hour having a bit of fun
with blitz I'm not sure what what
YouTube what YouTube regulations are the
ID I think you're you're supposed to not
give concrete figures watch what you get
from them I give you an on concrete
figure it's not much it's not much yeah
I can play this pretty in a pretty
relaxed way because this is just along
the lines of what I give in my book
and can you there's a question how can
you improve tactics other than just
solving lots of tactical exercises now
you it's really doing the exercises I
don't think there's this any other way
the technical ability to Train technical
abilities and chest is very comparable
to training yeah there's stamina in
physical sports just to being able to
run for a long time and just by doing
more more more you also get better
better better there is no magic key down
okay it seems that he maybe wants to
play with efore here yeah okay i think
i'll start with this to have bishop b6
check available here i can also take but
should be six hmm
yeah I had the youtube channel when I
was still working in the office so this
is not there is no um change that same
I record my five-minute games on oh this
is there is no particular time I think
we should be six was my idea 3006 3,700
followers are not enough to gain a lot
of money yeah that's definitely true
this is not this is not really doing
much and 100,000 subscribers and this is
subscribers don't make you any money I
know only clicks on advertisements make
money so um it's nice to have 100,000
but it's not it's not fantastic no I
already enjoy enjoy making the the
videos I mean I really the Blitz videos
I just liked like to play blitz anyway
so this is something that is not in any
way um a hassle I'm producing the the
some instructional more complicated
content it's a little bit of a different
story I still like to do that but it's
something that it costs a lot of time
and in I simply sometimes don't find the
time I don't like to take this but I
think it's technically easiest
I think I've been the d5 pawn this is
why I dad took just bring the King up
now and round this point up I that's a
good north we're still I can go to
yourself
yeah that looks like that looks like a
win check what sometimes if you talk
about producing the videos what
sometimes it's not easy the line goes
round recaps let's say formed for title
steel or tournaments like that going to
play one more game start and I really
like to do those but what sometimes is
an issue is that to be somewhat
interesting those videos have to be made
rather shortly after the round is
completed and the problem sometimes this
if you have little time in this
particular on this particular day and or
what something like that for the final
round for example I had it over the
board game which was quite quite testing
and i also had lots of teaching work on
that on that on the day after that and
that was really difficult to get to get
it in this this kind of video and
ultimately I didn't I simply didn't
didn't manage to make it and as nobody
asked for it I didn't didn't make it yet
this is sometimes a problem you cannot
really schedu with this properly you
just have to make it when the round is
completed and quite often yeah if the
time time time situation is not good you
have a problem okay i try to this is an
interesting position here against my
Stern was very high rated at the moment
is fluctuating with this rating
that's an idea the chat crowd found
crowdfunding videos um that's an
interesting idea actually an interesting
idea okay jab this is the kind of
position where you almost have to sec on
g4 otherwise this is a complete disaster
however this also might be a complete
disaster so let's do it quickly at least
check
Kim g3 is what I expect then I probably
have to shoot a 5 which might or might
not be still interesting I don't really
know feels like the only move that at
least stairs up some trouble now it
takes d4 that's F whoa check this is
this is Oh announced that I thought that
this would be chance would be good
probably or is he working with some
stuff to e6 taking on d4 is also move
for every check but ok let's think about
this for a moment if i take here and it
plays like Bishop e6 rook f2 King g3 hmm
not sure what happens there
I take on d4 Bishop takes every check
King f1 home check on edge too kinky one
that doesn't lead anywhere
Jack yeah let's do this and that's
actually funny if it takes f three years
is really interesting I can go to h2 mmm
I didn't ch2 coming oops we're still F
to maybe check
Saudi five maybe four Bishop 2d6 or look
look at four is actually interesting for
Luke h4 that's a wild game probably
entirely incorrect from blacks point of
view but anyway it wasn't easy for him I
think not not sure I'm not saying that
I'm winning I really have no idea what's
going on here but it feels dangerous now
Luke age 4 is a pretty pretty hard
pretty hard to meet
yeah Miko's air says I hope you to be
around for a long time lots of gems in
here from Chester games to programming
tutorials yeah I think we can be pretty
sure that YouTube is one of the websites
I will probably be stay around for um
yeah basically ever so I thought rook f8
should kill now Queen age 3 i'm now that
also should win actually Queen at shree
rook a king of to look of a check wins
the house check check so I actually got
lots of rating points back with my last
couple games back to 2411 yes okay and
can you recommend a book about the
Queens gambit hmm Queens gambit is a
wide range opening and many many lines
um there are many specialists books um
for repertoire works for white there are
a couple of things around maybe books by
last shunned off are interesting but
it's hard to recommend one book there
are so many specific ones books on the
slab on the semi slab on the tirage
whatever there are so many tattoo give
give one recommendation okay guys I hope
you enjoyed it I played badly at the
beginning but sort of recovered at the
end getting in some some entertaining
games maybe not very correct once but at
least it was was good fun hope you
enjoyed it I'll be back next Monday same
time same channel so make sure to be on
again in ya next week next Monday bye
bye